[Music]
hey guys whatever we remember habitat
records you all I have but they don't
you play I bought one of those you weird
good frog hey Crosby good table
yeah and they like I guess they warp
your records but I don't know that and
so I have Eminem records and I was
playing it and it's like well the real
Slim Shady please stand up and like
that's not what that song sounds like I
am the only records that I had in my
house where of my grandpa he had these
records of this ha ha ha it's [__]
sad ass Korean music I've been crying
for [__] three hours because it's our
folk music is sad so it's just I would
wake up to this area might receive
Corian sorrow music well it's because
they connect to them by grab by the
quarter like this it's like the worst
thing I've ever heard of my life but I
don't understand how he connected to
that [__] like it's like our current
it's like listening to music now and
there's somebody doing like the
milliwatt do they have Korean Grammys
where the winner like all for their
famous song
but like the lyrics if you translated
it's like somebody took my wife away and
they killed my chil is like Mexican
music yeah there it goes but Mexican
music way back but Mexican music is like
happy tones but really sad lyrics it's
like dude it's like [__] killed that
[__] bird all the dope but it's
all like I always think to talk about
some happy carnival [__] yeah losing
country music is all sad too it's like
it's always about his wife leaving him
or something no you know that little
yodeling kid you know I'm saying you
know you they remix his [__] into like
some like EDM [__] but he has like an
original track it's [__] dope it's a
country song right it's [__] fire
dude I don't even like country music but
it's called like if I if I was famous or
something like that right and it's a
song about he'd rather had the girl than
just be famous and dude I was like go
kid no it's an original song you gotta
find that [__] it's [__] fire dude
made me cry I put it on my [__] spot
like dude have you heard the EDM remix
of like the Microsoft Windows not
welcome it's so
this first single this kids like eight
years old or some [__] it's amazing dude
famous for loving good listen to this
[__] did it fire
oh it's getting me right now Horace a
beautiful image you connect I'm on a
horse right now in the sunset [__] my
mom loves country countries her [__]
isn't this kid home I heard a song yeah
I like the song
[Music]
he's like a country Justin Bieber this
is original it's an I don't know if he
wrote it but it's an original song cuz
like who does he loved it this hard use
you're eight years old but that it's
amazing when Michael Jackson would seem
in Jackson five you're like how the [__]
do you think know those emotions my
favorite song of all the time is is
who's loving you my Jackson five I know
he's like you know the key to love is
have an abusive father that means you
doing perfect like into perfection you
know that's basically how he got worried
the whole time we you made it to real we
feel the love you made it to real you
made it to real chuck-e-cheese good
scenes for my birthday thank you for the
shirt by the way
would you get it where'd you get it from
I've got it did the [__] geriatric
turd did see my new shirt oh yeah yeah
you said the janitor said this morning
oh so this morning I was like walking
down the Hondo night all go to work and
I'm like yep and I didn't realize it's
so posh you know I'm pretty sure he
doesn't think you were gonna check you
cheated maybe he thinks you're the
manager the janitor maybe wouldn't see
somebody Chucky Cheese get mad
aggressive so the next time somebody
said just curse them out all gonna work
for your sake
cheese [__] that's it now be
better yeah you know be cool if
chuck-e-cheese employed like like petal
hunters and then like they actually let
the pedophiles come in to Chavo
I missed that show Chris Hansen yeah
yeah I miss it cause of how they would
catch it I couldn't watch that show the
same after the South Park made fun of
him oh yeah I'm Chris Hansen
I think the only way that chuck-e-cheese
catching paddles would work is if they
took the pizza away cuz I think white no
matter how much I go tell us a pet all
right no matter how much I love kids
as soon as the pizza comes as a
distraction and I'm not doing a good job
he said imagine Oh imagine I can only
imagine how those can look past food I
don't know any pedals if a crackhead can
pass food and just smoke crack yeah like
pedos like candy - it doesn't mean
they're not handed and out I'm getting
kids of their van yeah you're allowed to
like it your lot of like the bait
you're gonna bait your own kids yeah
wait what are you doing with your kids I
want to get all of you guys and then
we're gonna get a van and then we're
going to entice one of my kid Oh your
kids dumb no but see it's not gonna be
me they're always gonna be somebody else
and if they get in the van and they get
for the candy we're gonna jump the child
well you say we're gonna be in the van
waiting in the mass and but we're gonna
have somebody Alice and actor come in so
hey kid you want to come like yeah of
course and if they come in does only
that really we talked about the kids oh
they don't beat them up and it's not the
same thing but they're pretty much they
work with those YouTube channel people
the parents and they pretty much get the
kids to go to this pedos house see
that's too serious no cuz I'm actually
just gonna what my kids eyes well that's
on you though for not teaching your kid
again a fan clubs you could teach your
kids and then we should beat your ass
they do the exact go that be great right
so it's like no you know what it is not
it's not me beating up the kid it's like
now you have to watch your dad get beat
up by his closest friends cuz I did a
bad job at the judges jump my ass I was
that kid I'm so stupid and my parents
actually beat my house so we had a field
trip day I think it was like in third
grade or something we had a field trip
day where we actually leave the school
campus and we walked to the park and
then they were like
don't talk to strangers don't do any of
that stuff doesn't matter if they have a
dog doesn't matter if they have candy
you don't talk to them so yeah we're all
in the line you know you hold hands and
[__] dragged across the border you don't
know there's all these signs of like
whole family family suitcase with shirts
plans I do the [__] picture is an
animated cartoon and it's so it looks
like they're dragging their family house
like their family doesn't want to go so
then we walk to the park and then it was
like me and like two other little
friends right and then we see this guy's
sitting on the bench with this little
like shaggy dog
like our dogs and he's like do you guys
want to pet it we're like yeah so we
start petting the dog really quick we're
talking about look at this child being
dragged suitcase with clothes why no no
suitcase dude but it's a girl is like
humanism but that's what I see the
little girl or one of the signs the
girls airborne she clearly does not want
to go she's bleeding back this way and
the pears come on like my friends mommy
so then yeah we start putting this dog
and then our teacher gets pissed at us
and she's like you guys should not be
doing that you can't talk to strangers
and they somehow I guess she told my
parents and as soon as I got home I got
beat my ass oh like a sweet little old
guy he was an old guy that was like yeah
but we could have been raped from an old
dioxis that's the first thing they told
us pictured you like your mom telling
you right like right in front of the
door and right when you open right when
you open the door there's a guy with a
lollipop and a dog you think your mom
would you just go hey basically I was
that kid cuz I think I think I'd be that
old man like I follows lonely as [__]
cuz I love kids I would just bring the
[__] dogs out there to be a kid
magnet it so I could talk and like chill
with kids and [__] why do you want to
talk and chill with kids because they're
[__] cute when a girl
Oh Jerry I'm a grandpa you know like
it's playing chess
bad they spank like mothballs I'm trying
to chill with kids kids are [__] dumb
no like they just do they just say crazy
[__] and they're just fun to observe
isn't that so sad though like nowadays
like you can't even just like be an old
man that just wants to talk to kids it
kind of sucks cuz now you have to do
this like you see a kid as an old did
you like hate kids would you like to pet
my dog but please sign this affidavit
beyou all ADEs could do it right what's
what's up with that
I don't trust old ladies even more we
don't have ticks it's like if old people
can go feed ducks at the pond they
should be able to [__] pretend that
they have grandkids - well these are
worse did you guys have how the
Predators at your old elementary school
you couldn't even tell if you know when
I was little what about now it was Isaac
because like I remember when I was in
elementary school I thought it was the
norm but then now growing old on my way
that's kind of weird that every month we
always had some police drawing of a guy
like watch out for Antonio Vasquez or
for whoever seems like you don't call
the printers his name is Steve my friend
he got me the best everyone my parents
didn't teach me [__] about the danger or
that I [__] learned that in school
take a bite out of crime if someone
tries to grab you you [__] bite them
and then I wouldn't stop with that dick
I thought I would crack this stranger
danger we had a safe word Somu my mom
came up with a safe word so if a
stranger came by it was like get in the
car I know your mom or something the
safe word is okay okay right no so they
had to say the safe word and no one said
it was Fox because we learned about that
on Fox on this Fox Channel yeah they're
like you should have a safe word so it
was Fox I'll never forget that and so if
they're like hey I know your mom she
told me to pick you up what's the safe
word uh-huh please yeah nope
I was probably very undesirable no but I
was wet couldn't wait to use it do you
even need us a flirt cuz I could have
just sworn like if I don't
all this [__] I'm not getting in
the car well if they were like your mom
told me to pick you I but a lot of
people picked you up yeah yeah I knew
who they weren't before they picked me
up or my mom would just call the school
and nobody hey bar yeah your mom's
calling you and go yeah oh this person's
gonna pick you up there okay
so someone if someone drove by and they
were like hey my mom your mom told me to
pick you up
we bought you you're a [__] liar get
the [__] away from me oh you customers
you're like he did get kidnapped but
they just threw him away cause he
thought him so yeah you got to be
getting the car kid get the [__] out
strangers but then like every year when
they had the gift wrap sale or like
you're each selling chocolate sister you
have to go to strangers and ask them to
buy face be with your parents that I
wasn't with my parents
I went door-to-door I picture a
neighborhood with just a bunch of
rapists and that his pictures up there
saying don't pick up this if you see
this kid say no to the band or try to
open up the door kid you were taught to
bite bad people
what no that was just an analogy yeah it
wasn't like literal learn how to keep
your family and your community safe and
help pick up right out a crime oh yeah I
thought that if they're like if if
people with someone grabs you or
whatever and then you [__] you bite
them and then you punch them in the
balls and you run yeah I remember the
balls yeah I always remember I remember
all that from from three ninjas that was
like
yeah have you guys heard of this podcast
called sorting scale
mm-hmm so sort of scale I don't want to
like
butcherin or anything but just from the
few episodes that I did listen to it's
about like serial killers or people
would like perverse who do like really
perverse crime what's it called a sword
in scale sword instead I don't like
probably I feel like 80% of them sounds
like a cookie but oh that kind of or
weightloss show they it's like
interviews of what these like serial
killers and like rapists and there was
this one guy where he was just it's kind
of weird like he was talking about how
he used to abuse his family and so he
groomed his his youngest daughter to be
a sex sex slave since the day she was
born
Wow so it's weird cuz you hear these
guys talk right and it's so emotionless
he goes yeah she was my property so you
know I just trained her so she was a kid
and when she was on the potty and she
wouldn't go pee I would beat her to
death
I nearly beat her to death until she
would take a piss of [__] so she'd be in
the bath for about four hours and then
he will lock his wife into a shed in the
backyard and then so he was like
sometimes like I would rape her like six
or seven times a day and it wasn't
enough so I have to get another girl and
rape them to what like you know here
like these like in Tarrant like it's
like an interrogation but they're having
them speak why did you do to the Moody
walking freak no cuz we're talking about
like you always do that so David has
this thing where we're like the [__]
energy is up here and then he brings in
this real life story that's [__] up he
did its to us when we were I think we
were all driving back from maybe eating
tacos out Gordo on the [__] highway
he's like yeah so we're all like haha
this is cool hot it was yeah uh one time
we were on an honor or high with my
throws on a highway and he like killed
someone listen to me but I'm also the
person that brings it back up
your stomach from watching a lady [__]
and then you're like and then he raped
another little girl and then another
girl like it's it's kind of great like
cuz we're talking about this but it's
weird how like I when I was listening to
it is very perverse but it's kind of
weird how this guy doesn't have any
emotions yeah you get curious and you
want to learn Oh most of those guys are
just talk like it's like nothing like
it's like it's not yeah it's like they
need a lot to feel something like so
because they don't feel anything I need
to feel stuff I want to go to Six Flags
[Laughter]
dude take me to Six Flags I thought ever
since we kissed again
what you need to do is see if she wants
to go on rollercoasters of [__] just go
during the Knott's Berry Farms Food
Festival you just get the grub on [__]
while she just goes on rollercoasters
that's not like fun I don't need him to
go I just want us to go - you like
that's three that's so funny cuz she
included me that she just shortened it a
little bit yeah rights are so there's so
much different than six legs right so I
love Six Flags rights because they were
the gnarliest one oh yeah crazy but the
older I get the more aware I am of my
own mortality and I'm like oh [__] I
could really die it might this thing
could go bong here this what I'm doing
right here let's go back to the serial
rapist now you know it's so creepy
because I love like adrenaline I love
feeling that feeling in my tummy yeah
but you get it get in his car oh yeah I
got it I wanna feel dread a little
adrenaline put okay get a bunch of
clothes pins right put a hundred dollar
bill all over your shirt yeah right get
well Skid Row yeah go to Skid Row
yo I'll one-up you you want to feel
adrenaline yeah get in the car with
Muriel that's it they might connect
though she's so [__] funny dude like
we're in the car and she'll say it's
like crazy [__] I'll be like hey you're
driving a little insane and I like grip
the [__] [__] right she goes I don't
know what you're talking about every
time I Drive nobody honks at me I was
like just cuz you choose not to hear it
doesn't mean people
honking at you so literally she'll just
like it's like the family got [__]
people are honking she goes I don't hear
anything she didn't give up [__] do you
like that's for the other person and so
for me I thought it was just me and [__]
but then you know I went to Joshua Tree
this past weekend her friend said the
same thing big ole I hate being in a car
with it because it's so [__] scary so
now I know how easy okay I love that
feeling right so then not until recently
I looked over the balcony of Steve's
room when we're at playlist and for some
reason like I started my body started
shaking like I was actually scared that
was me for Paris I looked over that
balcony all adrenalin [__] go like
this and let somebody shoot right around
your body we just need a rollercoaster
Joe you don't need all that all those
things that's adrenaline though I love
the roller coaster probe with the click
click click click the one that goes up
no I haven't done Knott's Berry Farm or
even at California Adventure this the
Superbowl tell no oh I love that one
that's the one every time like it never
it never tells you when it's gonna drop
it you're just like you have really good
funnel cake there any good pan for gold
the not fair yeah you know what's so
weird about Knott's Berry Farm like it's
supposed to be a place that has like
safe barriers and high tech like [__]
rollercoaster but it looks like a
[__] old western town like it doesn't
make me feel safe you know it's all
rigged it's so [__] weird though it's
like hey go on this [__] machine that
might kill you but look yee-ha you
should like a tumbleweed go through the
scariest roller coaster is that uh you
know when you're driving to Vegas at
state line and then there's that I
rolled that shape that was scary you
because you could actually fall out of
that like you're only a lap belt and
it's like way down here yeah it is so
rickety and your air like oh my god I'm
actually gonna fall out of this cuz this
shit's not speaking did we go together
oh yeah I think we wrote that little the
like the waters of the water it was so
bootleg I love that [__]
I felt like I played a football game
after that I was so beat up from like
clinging and like cuz it goes through
the casino oh that's a little fun of the
book actually just like bangs you around
yeah it's like the Rickey deist roller
coaster and like it's a lap belt but
it's like the lap belt is here and so
you're like I could fly out any minute
what's the [__] ride called abusive
father like what the [__] I feel like
the older I get it talked about abuse
and rape more David no no no I feel like
the older I get the more scared less
scared I am
oh I've done rollercoasters so much
right we're like when we did go-karts
always like before I used to think that
was fast
but now it's too slow no it's pretty
seamless really no it's the other way
around you're supposed to be precautious
when you get older because you have a
lot more to lose and you're less on
drugs then you used to right no I feel I
feel I mean mm-hmm okay I I did
something by a clip oh that was scary
I was scary and I was like what the [__]
I'm not supposed to be scared
well you are it's not like it's not like
you fell off the cliff I'm not supposed
to be scared
[Laughter]
[Music]